you are watching ColdFusion TV
nokia one of the most widely recognized
and on average universally liked
companies ever to grace the face of this
earth when I say the name Nokia you may
think of a phone but you may also think
of something bit more abstract and
deeper than that it may remind you of
brighter times of fond memories my very
first phone was Nokia and this may be
the case of many of you guys Nakia was
the company that could do no wrong until
of course they eventually did so what's
the story behind this company and how
could a company so successful so
influential and so pioneering slip
between the cracks to become a shoal of
what it once was before eventually
evaporating into the shadow of Microsoft
the lessons learned from Nokia could
teach us something important let's begin
Nokia's history dates back to 1865 when
a mining engineer Frederic Ida stem set
up his first wood pot mill in southern
Finland a few years later he opened a
second mill on the banks of the Nokian
virtual River this river inspired him to
name his company Nokia and I think
that's kind of interesting because he
would have no idea how widely recognized
this name would become soon Nokia
expanded into other industries such as
rubber cables tires TVs boots and more
so it's safe to say that the early Nokia
was a completely different company to
the one that we know and love with that
in mind let's move on to when Nokia
became the nokia that we actually know
today we'll pick up the story in 1960s
at this time there was a great deal
going on in the world social political
and new ways of thinking were gaining
momentum in diverse places but
overshadowing all of this was something
particularly ominous the cold war in the
mid to late 1960s the conflict wasn't so
ice-cold a nuclear war was actually a
possibility the communist superpower the
USSR was testing their bombs and the
steadfast capitalist USA was testing
their bombs both of these parties were
testing with increasing ferocity
these tensions made the whole world
nervous the tensions were felt even in
the rather neutral country of Finland
and they were taking action they were
preparing for the worst the Finnish
government wanted military research into
radio telephone communications to help
their country realize the full potential
of reliable military communication a
little company called Nokia got the
contract from the expertise developed in
communication later developed into a
civilian radio car telephone network
that spanned the whole country by the
start of the 1970s the system was very
primitive by today's standards because
he actually had to take turns to speak
but the real boom and start for Nokia
began in the 1980s when mass production
took place the company began to expand
into mass production methods of
manufacturing the economy of scale meant
added features less cost a smaller size
and a cheaper price the company exported
50% of their product and expanded
globally by 1985 the Finnish company
finally hit the big time when they hit
the USA by teaming up with Tandy during
this time the concept of a mobile phone
was incredible you didn't have to slot
money into a machine to make a call you
didn't have to wait in a payphone line
and you didn't have to be at home hoping
that the cable could stretch just that
little bit longer anywhere anytime was
the idea the vastness of the market was
soon realized when sales exceeded
predictions by 3,000 percent it just
seemed that people love to talk and
Nokia may have been onto something here
it said that the secret to Nokia success
in the late 1980s was their ability to
tailor to different markets in the
mobile industry while keeping the
efforts going in various other
industries in 1987 Nokia created the
mobile a city man it was the first Nokia
phone to make major news headlines due
to the fact that Mikhail Gorbachev the
leader of the Soviet Union at the time
was spotted using the phone during press
conferences the slogan for the city man
was straight connection for those of you
who need independence but it wasn't all
smooth sailing and in 1988 to 1989
Nokia found itself in a crisis you see
at this time the Soviet Union collapsed
and there was a major recession in
Europe so the demand for Nokia's diverse
later products seemed to dry up over
because of this there was a change in
management and Jorma Ollila a former
citibank banker came to take over a CEO
in 1992 as a banker german new a thing
or two about management he would make
the one decision that would shape the
company's future for the next decade and
a half he decided to shut off all the
company's extra proceeds and focus
directly on Mobile's assuring in Nokia's
golden period the 1990s this is the
decade that Nokia truly left everyone
else in the dust though the undisputed
champions of one of the fastest growing
industries in history and with that
being said that's all we're gonna leave
part one of the series
thanks so much for watching guys and if
you're interested in more videos like
this while you want to see the rest of
the series don't forget to subscribe and
maybe leave a comment saying what your
first Nakia phone was anyway this is V
indiegogo thanks for watching cold
fusion and I'll see you again soon for
the next video cheers guys have a good
one cold fusion
it's me thinking